BTS is everywhere,
and people can't get enough of them.
- BTS!
- Please welcome, BTS!
After finding success in South Korea,
they were able to make a
huge splash internationally.
Tickets for their global
concert tour sold out
within hours of being released.
They became the first-ever K-pop act
to make a No. 1 album with
2018's "Love Yourself: Tear."
And they're not stopping anytime soon.
Their newest album "Map
of the Soul: Persona"
is already looking like
it'll be a huge hit,
and of course, people
camped outside for days
to see them perform live
on "Saturday Night Live."
But BTS wasn't an overnight sensation.
It took them years of hard
work to get to this level.
BTS debuted in June 2013,
and they quickly gained
a dedicated fan base
thanks to social media.
They show a lot of love and
appreciation for their fans
who they even named A.R.M.Y.,
which means Adorable
Representatives for MC Youth.
And in 2017, BTS won the Top
Social Artist Billboard Award,
breaking Justin Bieber's
six-year winning streak
and making them the first K-pop act
to win a Billboard Music Award.
Unsurprisingly, they won again in 2018.
- BTS!
- [Narrator] BTS also
became the first K-pop band
to perform at the American
Music Awards in 2017,
gaining them even more
fans internationally.
But their fans don't just love them
for their mind-blowing performances.
They love BTS for their
socially conscious music.
BTS writes their own music,
which tackles complex topics
like bullying, mental health,
and societal pressures.
BTS stands for Bangtan Sonyeondan,
or Bulletproof Boy Scouts in English.
According to member J-Hope,
the name signifies the group's desire
to block out stereotypes,
criticisms, and expectations
that are imposed on adolescents.
Essentially, they're bulletproof.
Their work is also inspired
by literature, art, and even philosophy.
Their music video for "Blood,
Sweat, and Tears" references
and showcases a few
famous European paintings,
and their newest album is based
off the book "Jung's Map of the Soul,"
which explores the theories of
Swiss psychiatrist Carl Jung.
Mostly, fans can't get enough
of the chemistry among the members.
The band consists of seven members:
RM,
Jin,
Suga,
J-Hope,
Jimin,
V,
and Jungkook.
Since becoming a global sensation,
they've collaborated
with many famous artists
including American DJ Steve Aoki
who remixed "Mic Drop"
and collaborated on "The Truth Untold."
On the heels of the remixes,
Aoki featured BTS members
Jungkook and RM in "Wasted on Me."
This is the members' first
all-English-language song.
BTS also released an alternative version
of their song "Idol"
featuring Nicki Minaj.
The music video received
over 45 million views
in its first 24 hours on YouTube,
breaking the then-record previously set
by Taylor Swift with "Look
What You Made Me Do."
Their newest album features
even more collaborations,
this time with Ed Sheeran on
a track called "Make it Right"
and Halsey on "Boy with Love."
This collaboration is already
blowing up on YouTube.
With yet another hit on their hands,
the sky's the limit for BTS.